[Applause]
um
foreign
elders and my brothers and sisters i
welcome all of you with the islamic
greetings assalamu alaikum
foreign
mercy and blessings of allah subhanallah
all of you
it's the honor
and a great pleasure
for me to be awarded
the islamic personality of the year
hijri 1434
that is c 2013
by the dubai international holy quran
award
under the patronage of sheikh mohammed
bin salman
all praises are due to allah alone and
it's only because of his help
his blessings and his mercy
that whatever i could achieve little bit
in the way of dawah
and i received many appreciations
and many congratulations i pray to allah
to not hold me responsible
for what they think about me
to forgive them for what they don't know
about me
and to make me better than what they
think about me
all praises i did to allah subhanahu wa
alone
without his help and mercy
whatever little bit i've achieved would
not have been possible
and i'd like to thank
the support of my family members
for supporting me in the field of dawah
especially my parents
my father dr bukharim nike
my mother mrs roshan knight
and particularly my wife
who has supported me from the day of my
marriage
and
i consider her
that she is the best gift that allah has
bestowed on me
and
she is
a
and also
my brother dr muhammad my sister doc my
sister naila and my other family members
my friends
my staff
and my supporters
for helping me to achieve whatever
little bit i've done
the person responsible for me
to get into the field of dawah
was late sheikh ahmadin
he is the person
who converted me
from
the doctor of a body to the doctor of
the soul
it was in 1997 when i was doing my
second year medical college when i met
him for the first time
and he inspired me
to become a die
he is my guide he is my mentor
and it was the desire of my mother
that i should become
a heart specialist
somewhat similar to dr chris bernard as
you may be aware the writer chris
barnard was the first doctor who did the
first heart transplant in any human
being and he too hails from south africa
like shaykh
and when i asked my mother
that do you want me to become like
sheikh didat or dr kris banan
she said both
later on when i got involved in the
field of dhawa started giving lectures
having debates and i asked the same
question to her after i shared my talks
and speeches and my debates that would
you like me to become like sheikh didat
or chris banan she said i can sacrifice
a thousand kris bernard for one sheikh
dida
and
sheikh dhidad he was an icon he was a
man with a mission may allah grant him
jannah
today
my mission
in life is to spread peace
islam comes from root word salam peace
and today the most important tool or
rather the most important weapon today
is the media
it can convert
black into white day into night hero
into a villain we run into a hero
unfortunately muslims are backward as
far as using dawah as far as using media
for davos concern
with this
mission
seven and a half years back
alhamdulillah we launched the peace tv
english the production takes place from
bombay and uplinking is from dubai and
london
dubai covers the whole of asia middle
east africa australia london covers the
whole of europe and america and
the dubai especially the media city in
the way and the government of dubai have
been very helpful and has been
instrumental in making peace tv popular
today peace tv alhamdulillah is the
largest washed islamic satellite channel
in the world having a viewership of more
than 100 million
it is not only the largest washed
islamic satellite channel it is the
largest washed
religious standard in the world
five years back we launched the peace tv
urdu which today has a viewership
of 80 million
and two and a half years back
we launched the peace tv bangla which
has a viewership of more than 50 million
alhamdulillah peace tv network is the
largest watch islamic satellite channel
in the world
and it is been running by the support of
the muslim ummah
and for it to sustain
we require a walk
today the award that i've received along
with it
i also lift a million dirham i've
received along with the award i would
like to donate this money million dirham
to the box of the peace tv
and i request
the businessman
the muslim ummah from the world to
support this work so that the peace tv
network can be self-sufficient
also blessed me
with three good children
i have a son
his name is fatik who's 19 years old and
two daughters
they too
have supported me and i pray to allah
that may they continue the mission which
i have started and allah has blessed my
son
all my
situation all so you know arabic the
language i don't arabic language i know
all my three children masala they speak
very fluent arabic loga fasa all three
are black belts and martial arts
and my son mashallah has been giving
lectures since a young age of eight
years
and today
when we had the last conference in 2009
the peace conference in bombay he was
the youngest speaker at the age of 15.
i pray to allah that may he give him
multiple times
more support than what he has given me
so that he could continue the work
to continue this mission
twelve years back i started the islamic
international school in bombay
and a couple of years back
in islamic international school in
chennai
the main purpose of the school is to
have education for both the worlds
from the age of two and a half we teach
the children arabic and english
by the time they reach standard files
they can understand the quran by the
time they reach the ninth and ten
standard they can translate to a great
extent
they have to be black bill by the time
they reach standard five
and the degree is from the cambridge
university it's not a degree by any
normal indian school
or a muslim school it's from cambridge
university uk and allah blessed us we
teach the children from the age of three
and a half
public speaking
they're able to handle microphones at a
young age and by time they become
teenagers they give lectures in front of
thousands of people
and allah blessed us that not only were
we able to
perform in the field of dawah
year before last
when the first batch of the islamic
international school appeared for the
old level in the cambridge board the
girls that came out first
by allah's health and grace out of five
subjects in the cambridge board in the
igcse
in four subjects she got hundred out of
hundred
mashallah
she has the muhajiba
she knows arabic as language
she's blackmailing martial arts half of
the quran
so we want our children
to be the future generation the leader
and within the intention we want to
spread these schools in different parts
of the world inshallah
we have plans of starting a school in
dubai too the islamic international
school the way
and we are just started the process and
inshallah the school will be completed
in the next two years in september 2015
and the government of dubai has been
very helpful especially the knowledge
fund
in
giving us a land at a very cheap lease
and i pray to allah that may such
schools
be
evolved in different parts of the world
i would like to thank
sheikh mohammed bin rashid maktoum who i
believe is a visionary
in making this dubai helmet dubai a
landmark
in the map of the world
and the development
and
also the government i would like to
thank
the dubai international holy quran award
for
having this competition every year and
for encouraging thousands
of muslims to become fast throughout the
world
and my message to the muslim um is
that make quran
the source of guidance the word of allah
subhanahu ta'ala and make it a point
that you read the quran in the language
you understand the best every day if you
know english in english if in urdu
reading urdu
if you know tamil read in tamil make it
the source
the guide of your book
the book of allah
make it the source of guidance
throughout your life
and i would like to once again thank the
holy quran award and let it end my
speech with the quotation of allah in
foreign chapter 16 verse 125 he says
invite all the way of the lord with
wisdom and beautiful preaching and argue
with them and reason with them in the
ways that the best man wishes
[Applause]
be
foreign